[Music]
how do things move in real life say a
ball is moving on a flat ground and
there's no external force acting on it
will the ball eventually come to a halt
yes it will have you ever wondered why
say you're skating on an ice rink and
your friend is skating on the road whose
movement do you think will be smoother
definitely yours when you hold a bottle
in your hand
why doesn't it just slip through and
fall sometimes when you're walking
around in a mall do you remember seeing
a caution sign to warn you about the
floor being wet what explains all this
the answer is friction the reason why
the ball eventually comes to a halt is
because of the force of friction the
reason why skating on an ice rink is
easier because the force of friction is
lesser there the bottle doesn't slip
through because the force of friction
between your hand and the bottle doesn't
allow it to do so if the floor is wet
the friction offered by it reduces and
there are chances that you might slip
and fall so what does this friction
we're talking about it's quite easy to
understand its concept friction is
nothing but a force it is the force
exerted by a surface where an object
moves across it in the first case when
the ball is moving in this direction the
force of friction is acting in the
opposite direction the force of friction
offered by the ice rink flow is lesser
than the force of friction offered by
the road hence skating on the ice rink
is easier and seems effortless the
bottle does not slip down because the
surface of your hand offers a friction
in the upward direction and in the case
of the floor in the mall the soapy water
reduces the friction offered by the
floor in the coming lessons we learn a
lot more about friction we see the
factors affecting friction wheel
understand if friction helps us in our
everyday life or not and we will also
cover the different types of freak
[Music]